no let's talk about the awards we
haven't really talked about them before
and there were three very important
awards this year yes indeed the first
award the individual FTTH awards was
awarded to Hardwick tauba whom you know
he is the former director general of the
FTTH Council Europe and before that he
was also the first president of the ftth
Council Europe which means that he has
been around for quite a while and has
really he gave you he obtained the award
because he is such a strong defender of
FTTH and has contributed to growing the
organization to what it is today and we
had the first for the first time -
operator FTTH awards the first one post
Luxembourg who they are the incumbent
operator in this country for deploying
fibre they actually have 50% coverage of
the population which is very impressive
for an incumbent operator and the second
operator not a level because they were
both equal in in the prize is India in
the eyes a an operator from Poland and
they have deployed fibre in the Greater
Poland rate region which is suburban and
rural suburban and rural area which is
great because we know that fibre has
very high impact and contributes to
bridging the digital divide so we were
very pleased and we were even more
pleased because actually a Poland did
really well in the markets at panorama
yes sir they've entered the rankings for
the first time along with a couple of
other countries exactly so yes this is
another announcement Poland Germany and
Croatia all three countries entered the
FT th ranking for the first time
so this means they now join the what we
call you know the lead leading economies
in ftth terms
the thing is though of course when you
enter the ranking it means that you have
just one percent penetration which means
that one percent of the households our
FTTH or HDTV subscribers so it's a good
sign it's going in the right direction
there's still work to be done but it's
it's nice to welcome some new countries
in the ranking anyway talking of
countries I think you've had a record
number here this week indeed yes in the
previous few years we had 86 85 87
different nationalities represented as
delegates in this event and this year I
was quite surprised I just got the
figures just before coming to this
interview we have 96 nationalities
represented which is quite amazing we
are we almost have people from all over
the world really coming to this event
which is and remains the largest ftth
focused event in the world
fantastic now one of the highlights I
know for you was the opening plenary
today 1500 people and more possibly but
tell us why it was a highlight it was a
highlight for me personally because I
had this dream of having this entire
plenary holding a sign showing their you
know wish to get fiber and in fact I
managed to have a thousand five hundred
people in the plenary holding this sign
it was really great we had a
photographer on stage take a magnificent
picture of all these signs it's really
impressive so I'm very happy that's
great well we all want the fibre and I
think the figures are showing that Moore
was a getting fiber which is great news
so thanks for talking to us thank you
very much Brian